you're an amazing dancer and I've seen
you dance before you're incredible you
are have you ever thought about being on
like Dancing with the Stars man I would
kill dance with the Stars first of all I
just don't want I'm ready for death for
the stars because you're gonna disappear
for five or six years first of it some
horrible happen to disappear right but
five or six years then you come back hey
we're keeping it right he's on Dancing
with the Stars Dancing with the Stars
yeah if I'm gonna so I miss it because
I'm long I'm lean you don't me yo oh I
know what you mean I am long and lean
and I my name is Michael tolls so they
call me twinkle toes and I think anybody
calls you twinkle toes
that might not be about the dance yeah
is called too much a burger yeah
Christmas elf there yeah what do you
what would your dance be if you went off
the wall I'm gonna tell you something
right now
never doubt me first of all Coenen all
right one of my most sensual moves that
I love dances I love when my lady is a
tango it's the most sensual dance ever
make it want to do a figure eight with
your breath a figure eight yeah here
your nipples are rock hard yeah you do a
figure eight you feel hot feels oh
that's nice cigarette figure and that
gets you in the mood for the tango its
hanger
oh pretty something but me hey man get
up here man so tango
hey my dear there's nobody else coming
who resembles the lady it's up you come
on okay
what do I do little bit what do I do now
first of all in a tango
do you want me do you want me Conan yes
yes have to act like you want I want you
I want you I want to okay I want you I'm
console I wants you but you have to want
me back I want you tangles gonna don't
work if you want me I want you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you